VICTOR DAVIS HANSON:
Right now, many Americans
have to be vaccinated
against the COVID virus,
or they're not allowed
to teach, or they're not
allowed to work in a hospital.
Yet the two million people that
are coming across the border,
there's no requirement
that they be tested,
or there's no requirement
that they be vaccinated.
So the United States, of
all countries in the world,
at its very founding
had the idea
that you could
become an American
if you crossed the borders and
you accepted the American idea.
So when people came from diverse
countries, they had skills,
they spoke English,
and they came legally,
and there was not whole
blocs of ethnic castes
that had grievances or they had
difficulties in assimilation
with the majority population.
And more importantly,
legal immigration
was welcomed because it
kind of reminded Americans
that there were people
who were very competitive,
and they wanted this system
of free market economics,
constitutional government,
a bill of rights
that was lacking in
their home country.
What happens when the host
itself, i.e., the United
States, has lost confidence
in its traditions and customs
and doesn't feel that
it should or has a right
or it wouldn't be nice to impose
their values on people who
are arriving across a border?
Then, immigration
turns from something
very desirable and positive
to something that can be
very pernicious and dangerous.
The corporate
establishment has been
a big advocate of open borders.
And it's been very hard to
write op-eds for the Wall Street
Journal or talk to the
Chamber of Commerce
because they feel
that immigration,
even if it's illegal, is very
good for their own bottom line.
And the Democratic Party
said, if you come illegally,
we will ensure that
you will not be
subject to the enforcement
of immigration laws.
We will provide you
with entitlements,
but we expect, in exchange,
fealty and loyalty and fidelity
at the polls.
And it explains why now we do
not enforce immigration law,
because too many parties have
too many vested interests.
And we look at the border.
And it is a construct.
It doesn't exist in reality.
People are simply
walking across.
And you have people
coming in vast numbers
from one direction.
They do not speak English.
They're not legal.
And we, the host,
are not the host
that we have been from
the prior 280 years.
But we feel diffident,
lack of confidence
about our own system.
We don't feel we want to
impose on our new visitors.
We feel it would be
cultural appropriation
to tell them that this
system is better than the one
they're leaving.
You add all of that up, and
you have chaos and the erosion
of the idea of citizenship.
[MUSIC PLAYING]